she's you know yeah of course I mean
she's going to have her own she's making
her own money she's going out she's
doing her job she's got us because
because to be honest for me personally
the opposite of that is really
unattractive as well if she's just
sitting around and she's not doing
anything yeah yeah you know what you
don't want that either but it's it's so
for me it's not so much about those
things it's more about okay what's our
attitude like okay is she Pleasant to be
around is she fun is she nurturing is
she you know all of those those things
um I was talking to one of my friends uh
the other day he was telling me that his
girl is so in her femininity that it's
easy for him to be in his masculine he
can be himself because she's not trying
to essentially be a man and be in a
masculine a masculine space or be in her
masculinity masculinity she is able to
be
feminine and he's able to be masculine
and just makes him feel like I can be me
and do you know how many men and women
are both waiting on to enter their
masculine and feminine right there are
women that are waiting who are masculine
women who are waiting to be feminine I
don't believe that they're just uh I
don't know I don't believe that I don't
I think like women when they say they
can turn it on and off it's a cop-out
and they're just not feminine yeah
someone had something that said like
femininity can't be gained it can only
like you're born with a certain amount
of femininity and then you'd lose it but
but then I think a lot of men and the
reason why I say this because I think a
lot of men in these days and times are
waiting to be masculine I don't know I
don't I don't agree with that you don't
think men are waiting to be mad because
I'll expanded it because the reason why
I say that is because I think men have
been told to be feminine for so long
like we're talking about I don't know
you know the metrosexual stuff
there's been a mantra that your
masculinity is bad okay and it's toxic
and you need to remove it from yourself
however it's a natural thing inside a
lot of men to do so what they so what I
think a lot of men are finding and I
think a lot of the reasons why that
Andrew Tates and the Kevin Samuels has
explode is because men are now saying
yes we can be masculine again we can be
ourselves we can look at these guys and
gain leadership and it's okay to be a
man and I think there's a lot of women
waiting to be feminine to also
you know I just don't think so like I
think for men it's like different like I
feel like men are like programmed to let
like I feel like I don't put it like men
are one way and like the world tells
them not to be right and women naturally
are but I just think once a woman's too
far gone it's like there's a no coming
back like I don't think she'll ever get
that like child like like innocence or
like like the I don't know the like the
natural femininity once she's like done
certain things I just think it's gone
it's really funny as well like traveling
to you know because we spent quite a lot
of time in like Eastern Europe and
places like that and and a lot of this
stuff is really cultural by the way
because obviously we're sitting in
London now you know we you know people
are American and so on it's it's like
like in the Anglo sphere this is what
we're really talking about when you go
to some of these other places it's less
pronounced yeah it's a bit of a cliche
because I think Poland is now a very
westernized country it's part of the EU
it's quite quite wealthy it's whatever
but
still there's a bit more polarity
between the genders still you know what
I mean like the women are very famously
very feminine you know to the fact it's
almost a bit of a cliche you know the
Polish women are very feminine there was
many sort of women from Ukraine there as
well and again very very feminine
Russian women also exactly yeah exactly
and um it's funny because uh we were I
was with uh my friend James Tusk and uh
we were in a restaurant in Warsaw we're
having a bite to eat and at the table
and we've just been you know all these
like beautiful feminine girls around
wearing their sundresses and then on the
table next to us there was this woman
from um this this female lawyer from New
York and she was just like screaming oh
my God like the canopies were terrible
you know all this kind of things we were
just like we just had our heads in our
hands because it was like oh we just
traveled to avoid all this stuff you
know right yeah so I think it is it's
like culturally determined but I think
like to your point
um when somebody is like that oh is I I
don't I don't I didn't feel that that
woman was sort of like just desperate to
unleash her feminine again you know what
I mean I think she she's now a boss babe
and that's that's and that's her Persona
yeah exactly I think for the right guy
women will be feminine because I've seen
it I've seen it where there there's been
a masculine woman or she's just very
like this is me this is what I'm gonna
say and you can't tell me different and
she gets with the guy and she's just
she's sorry but you know what I think
that is is it because I think a lot of
women are playing boss babe and they're
not really I do I think a lot of women
are because they feel like that's a
person that they need to have yeah I'm
gonna get the bag and I'm gonna be a
boss that's not you so just what what
are you doing I just feel like they
could only keep that up for so long it
comes out eventually like an
argumentative woman like you're telling
me you're gonna be married 20 30 40 50
years and you're like you're never gonna
be argument like I just think like once
a woman is so far gone and if she wasn't
raised by a wife like I I think I mean I
don't want to say it's hopeless because
you know obviously like
like what else is she supposed to do
other than try yeah but I just think for
the majority like I just don't see him
going back sorry going I was gonna say
like for the women who who say this all
for the right guy I think what they want
is just a man oh masculine them that's
too much of a battle and that is too
much of a better and when if that man
wins it can
it can almost
um tether on the line of toxicity and
that's where you get a man who has to be
extremely toxic to you tame a woman
who's masculine and I feel like that's
what they're asking for sometimes I I
I've never seen a woman who is masculine
all of a sudden because family feminine
yeah sorry go ahead yeah I've never seen
that happen so it's just like she's just
found a man that's extremely masculine
to the point where it's almost toxic and
she just has to Humble herself but it's
chaos continuously it's continuous chaos
like here someone say that I was just
trying to think it through really I
think
um I mean there's a quote I think it was
in that book mystery method you know
like one of the all the game or one of
those early words about dating and it
was ultimate ultimate masculinity
attracts ultimate femininity also
something like that and he was just
making the point that you need to
emphasize that polarity in terms of
Attraction
um so it kind of makes sense what you're
saying you know if if the the boss babe
you know suddenly this this sort of like
you know local looks like out of the
film Gladiator or something and you know
just just takes her up you know then
maybe she'll sort of ReDiscover her
femininity but how realistic that is in
in this day and age is is you know
here's the thing and the thing like
with the toxicity it's like also I think
guys are very conscious of their
behavior now and they're in many cases
not every case but in many cases they're
toning it down because they're like I've
got to walk on eggshells a little bit
yeah you know what I mean so yeah I mean
there's so many interviews I've done
where the guys I know they know the
answer because I'll ask them a question
that somehow brings like an
uncomfortable truth and they know the
answer but I could see I'm like oh I
can't say that like I don't want to get
in trouble with work or whatever like
and so they're almost like coerced into
being feminine because like being
feminine is more like
you know not being as direct we're like
being masculine is more you know direct
yeah or is it what is a toxic
masculinity and on the flip side is
there any toxic toxic femininity that
was my name
Amber Hood
Amber Heard toxic femininity 100 I think
on either end is this an abuse of your
power so if you are a feminine woman and
you recognize your femininity you can
gain you access
um things and you use it solely for your
purpose for you to gain and go somewhere
in Life or whatever it may be to me that
can be toxic even though it may not be
so loud and things of that nature but
you feel abusing your your natural power
the same with a man if you understand
you've got a level like if you can
dominate a room and you then you're
abusing the people who who fall under
you I think I would consider that to be
toxic so I think it's like managing your
back knowing your power and managing it
if you don't do that that's when it
becomes toxic
okay
I think I think what is what classes as
toxic masculinity nowadays is not
actually toxic
[Music]
I was at an event on Sunday right and
you know we were discussing masculinity
and feminine as he and I was speaking
you guys know the way I speak I was
speaking what I speak right and some
girl in front of me turned around and
said you give me toxic vibes
and I was like how old was she who the
[ __ ] is he yeah and secondly like what
just just expressing a
different opinion sometimes can be
called toxic and masculinity pick me
yeah you get me I called one too
remember she said not you that's because
she didn't want me to come for her
but but it's true like anything can like
be classes toxic nowadays yeah
sorry it's just it's all very subjective
isn't it yeah it's all this thing about
like oh my feelings were hurt therefore
no it like what I've seen is when they
say toxic masculinity they mean like
traditionally masculine rules and when
they say toxic femininity like they mean
the same thing like typically like the
left more okay like so because there is
a girl that was like more left that came
on the show or like I don't know woke I
guess and she sent me a whole article on
toxic femininity and it was talking
about how traditionally feminine like
behaviors like being a housewife that
sort of thing are toxic
yeah yeah look if a man was like I just
need you to cook clean and I'll bring
home the bacon you can do whatever you
want hey it's okay okay
exactly I'd be like all right but
remember but that totally goes against
what you've been sold though do you know
I mean like it totally goes against what
the whole boss [ __ ] and the whole boss
baby it's also not the reality like yeah
because because even like when you're
saying like oh you cook clean and bring
up what percent of women get to do that
like none yeah that's like maybe one in
four so like you have to still be
submissive and work yeah and most women
don't want to do that I'm not saying
full time but like like I think only 20
of women get to be Housewives yeah and
the thing is it gets confusing for men
because it's like oh I'm independent and
I'm going to be a boss [ __ ] but please
someone come and save me and lately be
their wife it's like as many of you you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible